when senior u.s and chinese officials
met in alaska last month
their encounter matched the freezing
temperatures outside
the u.s was in no position to lecture
china warned its top diplomat
young jesus the united states does not
have the qualification
to say that it wants to speak to china
from a position of strength
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
has been equally blunt
our relationship with china will be
competitive when it should be
collaborative when it can be and
adversarial when it must be
there had been hopes that under
president joe biden
the relationship would be less
confrontational than it had become
under his predecessor biden and chinese
president xi jinping
met many times when the two were vice
presidents
analysts say that biden's china strategy
is based on a stronger alliance with
allies
i think he's done a very good job at
messaging
which is to say to the chinese that the
the
old rules of the past don't apply
anymore and
and they've been very tactically astute
economic diplomatic and even military
tensions
between the two rival superpowers are
continuing to rise
relations are fraught on a number of
issues the south china sea dispute
the well-documented evidence of human
rights abuses
in xinjiang china's tightening controls
here in hong kong and taiwan the nearby
island republic over which china claims
sovereignty
and biden has lowered expectations of a
breakthrough on
another friction point with china north
korea
washington places denuclearization of
north korea
at its top of its priority list with
respect to pyongyang
that's not the case for beijing beijing
is more interested in stability
yet in one area at least there's a
promise of cooperation
at a virtual summit this week china and
the us
the world's two biggest carbon emitters
pledged to work more closely
on cutting their emissions a rare
display of collaboration
but one unlikely to be repeated on other
fronts
adrian brown al jazeera hong kong